one of your early jobs were an extra in
Star Wars Phantom Menace
yes and this was a great was was it a
good part I mean it you're an extra but
did you get it much screen time I did
about 10 times because they they sort of
repeated us I think it's to save money
I'm not quite sure
oh that's when they do a big crowd scene
they shoot like a hundred people and
then digitally they yeah we reproduce we
do that here there's six people in the
crowd and we have recreated them 17
times yeah and you're doing an amazing
job thank you everyone
yeah Andy's not even here right now yeah
contract thing yeah yes please don't
yeah I bite don't go near the robotic
Andy Richter I just love this we found
as still a Star Wars that you're
actually in we found you this is real
and I think it's there somewhere you
think there you are yeah that's you do
you ever look at the movie and and look
for yourself in that scene I have never
seen it you're in a Star Wars movie and
you haven't seen it no that might be a
first
that'll make Star Wars fans and they're
intense that will make them angry I know
I know I know they'll be they'll be very
angry about that
I shouldn't have admitted that well you
should know sorry
I've seen it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you've seen it several times haven't you
yeah it's one of your favorite
especially one yeah how many Star Wars
films have there been
you